tiene posibilidad después la sed lidera
el bloque conservador en alemán ya que
no solamente ha estado en el poder
durante los últimos 16 años sino que
también lidera en las encuestas aunque
en las últimas semanas ha sufrido
bastante por diferentes conflictos
internos sin embargo la chet no tiene
garantizada su llegada a la cancillería
en septiembre no solamente porque él es
un candidato relativamente poco popular
por ejemplo se le compara con marcus es
ahora el líder bávaro pero también
porque asume ese bloque conservador y
asume esa cancillería en momentos en que
el bloque está muy dividido como quedó
en evidencia en las últimas semanas así
que si bien la hace parte como favorito
no está garantizado que él vaya a ganar
las elecciones de septiembre 26 nuestro
corresponsal también nos explicó qué
posibilidades tiene annalynne havard
bokko candidata del partido de los
verdes frente a la cidh escuchemos
claro es que el partido verde va a jugar
un rol muy importante en las elecciones
de septiembre y de hecho en por primera
vez presento a un candidato oa una
candidata en este caso a asumir el rol
de canciller se trata de malena baro con
una política muy joven de 40 años que
colidera el partido verde y como llamen
sin el partido de verde tiene todas las
posibilidades de jugar un rol muy
importante en las elecciones de
septiembre es el segundo partido más
popular detrás del bloque conservador
así que es muy probable que o sea el
socio minoritario de una coalición o si
las encuestas siguen favoreciendo le
incluso puede ser un gobierno liderado
por los verdes por primera vez en la
historia de alemania